un pan très est une citation sur des
supports qui ressemble à des panneaux
électoraux
non ce ne sont pas des affiches
politiques mais bien un concept
artistique n'a pas beaucoup de femmes
dans l'espace public
et quand yonath et des voix la cdc des
jeunes filles photoshopée donc j'avais
vraiment envie de mettre les habitants à
l'honneur et puis deux
puis ce soient des femmes et puis ce
soit des vraies femmes quand j'essayais
de trouver un trait assez sensible et
potentiellement un peu fragile et de le
re contrastée avec des couverts à sévir
je me suis posé pas mal de questions
niveau de commandes montre les rides et
des marques du temps et j'ai fini par le
traité sur un calque différents
partenaires le superposer aux autres est
le nom de ce projet sorcières et
magicienne fait référence à ces femmes
qui se passait les savoirs de génération
en génération
cette transmission entre femmes et s'est
interrompue dans les années soixante à
peu près quand il ya eu cette libération
de la femme ce grand mouvement de
libération après la libération de la
femme ou en fait les jeunes filles ont
dit à leurs mères toi ce que tu as
m'apprendre ça m'intéresse plus et les
vieux truc j'en veux plus moi je passe à
autre chose et la transmission s'est
interrompu comme ça et je me suis aperçu
qu'en fait dans les villages dans nos
villages ses transmissions il a toujours
lieu ma grand mère m'a appris qu'il n'y
a pas de mal à être coquines ou encore
ma grand mère m'a appris à me battre
pour ce que je pense être juste
ces citations sont extraites d'entretien
fait avec les petites filles irène 75
ans est surprise par son portrait mais
ravis de partager son expérience
on peut leur apporter beaucoup je pense
union le vois pas ce qu on est une
famille nombreuse et il ya toujours eu
des enfants plat la maison et ils
recherchent pas les recherches qu'on les
écoute qu'on fasse des choses avec eux
mais pas des choses sensationnelles des
choses de
tout de la vie courante et voilà
jusqu'au 31 mars dix portraits seront
visibles dans 18 villes autour de briare
et de châtillon sur loire
une deuxième campagne sera menée en
octobre le projet doit durer jusqu'en
un recueil d entretien et d affiches
pourraient être publiées